Speaker 1: A Republican official has been banned
from Twitter after suggesting that Joe Biden,
the president, should be killed. Yes, this is
where we are, folks. It's 2023. And unfortunately,
this is where we are and we've got to deal with
it, the News-Times reports. Brookfield Republican
first Selectman Tara Carr kicked off Twitter
after post targeting President Biden. Now we
actually have the post and we're going to put it
up on the screen for you. There was a video here
of tweeted by the RNC research account, which
was a video of Kamala Harris saying we have a lot
to be thankful for in Joe Biden And Tara Carr,
the elected official responded to it by saying
he meaning Joe Biden, he's aiding and abetting
the enemy. Ready, aim, fire. One shot, one kill.
That simple. There is not a lot of nuance there.
There is not a lot of nuance there. That is a call
to shoot dead the president of the United States
from a Republican official. As I mentioned, she's
been kicked off Twitter. Oh, Twitter has a liberal
bias. Something just fell off my microphone. That
was weird. Twitter has a liberal bias. Twitter
has because they they said, oh, now all of a
sudden you get kicked off for calling for the
assassination of the president. What won't they
allow next? These folks are genuinely dangerous,
not because Tara car herself is likely to go and
kill Joe Biden, but because an environment in
which it is even remotely acceptable to say
these things, if particularly forget as an average
person, but as an as a Republican official to say
something like this. Anything short of complete
denouncement, disavowal, and if it's on a social
media platform, banning the person could be seen
as some kind of an endorsement or approval of it.
A Republican town committee chair, George Blast,
defended the post, saying that Carr was saying,
shoot the balloon, shoot the balloon, not Joe
Biden, and that it was taken out of context.
It genuinely doesn't appear
at all that that is what
she is arguing for. So there it is, another
insane action by these dangerous right wingers.